now good morning everybody and welcome
back our next star founders day donation
drive
just got underway here at channel 8
about 15 minutes ago
to celebrate our parent company's
anniversary we are giving back this year
to the salvation army and three square
food bank yep we're collecting canned
and non-perishable food bottled water
and clothes right here at channel 8 all
you got to do is come to 3228 channel 8
drive
between now and 6 this morning and if
you come early
you might spot a familiar face nate i
think someone's already there looks like
there's a big truck behind us here
what's going on
exactly right we just had a huge
donation we got the fellas here what's
your name sir i'm andy
hi andy who are you from industrial uh
supply and what did you bring i brought
you a full case of water for
three square in your donation uh there
are 84 cases in there
holy smokes the case for your workers
there's some cold water there
thank you so much now you know that
we're doing this to help the
charities as we mentioned three square
food bank and the salvation army
what that's ready to eat meals their
canned and boxed goods the
the food for unused meat bread and
produce from hospitality and grocery
outlets well the folks from the three
square food bank
well they do it all right we've been
tested
and i think we've proven ourselves to be
uh
battle tough it's been a year of quick
adjustments according to three square
food bank's chief operating officer
larry scott
during a normal year three square
distributes 4.5 million pounds of food a
month
during the pandemic that number
increased to 5.6 million pounds
each month the demand was extraordinary
for sure with unemployment at an
all-time high in southern nevada due to
the economic fallout of covet 19
food insecurity soared to record levels
with more than 360
000 people needing assistance and one in
four children
now lives in a food insecure home add to
that a variety of complications like
being able to distribute the food with
social distancing and keeping people
safe
fortunately the warehouse shelves did
not go bare with help from local and
national donors who rose to the occasion
and helped provide the food that was
needed you want bread cereal
federal programs allowed ccsd to
distribute food at most of the schools
throughout the year
scott says when you take a look back i
think everyone would look at this and
say
mission accomplished he credits our
hospitality industry that drives so much
of our economy
while resorts and hotels were forced to
shut their doors they never turned their
back on three squares mission
they continued to send out their
furloughed employees to
help us they gave us access to their
parking lots
they emptied out their freezers and
their coolers and their pantries and
provided us the food
so you know we are a we are a unique
community by
many many measures but i can say that
this big engine of hospitality that
drives our economy
is a really really generous donor and
something that we should be very proud
of in southern nevada
the doors to three square opened up once
again on may 27th to volunteers
back to business as usual the
opportunities to pack meals and sort
produce
pre-pandemic three square had 200
volunteers a day
right now the number is less than half
that the real heavy demand picks up
again when school starts back up in less
than two months
we have volunteers that donate money we
have volunteers that donate time
some who donate food during the pandemic
some sown masks
people volunteer in so many different
ways some are driving
and delivering food to seniors who are
homebound
so we just have a variety of different
ways
that people can help and at
threesquare.org it's a perfect map to
lead you
to where you can find your little niche
to be able to help in this effort
kirsten joyce 8 news now all right thank
you so much kirsten and that's exactly
what we're all about again andy from
industrial supply down in henderson
literally just drove up into your 100
year old company
you got us this cold water for us and
you brought us
eight eighty four cases on a pallet for
three square in your donation program
here we really
admire what three squares done during
the pandemic for the kids
and we felt we wanted to contribute to
it you're telling me that you're putting
out a challenge
right now putting out a challenge to all
the ppe
distributors special tool distributors
in the vegas valley
meet or exceed what we got
andy thank you so much and he's a loyal
viewer gets up and watches us at 4 30
every morning we'll let you get on with
your day and
let your buddy hit the road here but we
are going to be here until 6 p.m
john alex and sherry we want you to help
out as well so come on down to channel 8
32
28 channel 8 drive you drop the mic on
that one he did he threw down the
gauntlet i love that
way to go andy what a buddy andy that's
so cool thank you for watching
wow that is so wonderful yeah i like the
challenge all right so there
the the he's laid down the law anyone if
you're if you're a pp deliverer whatever
the case would be
you got to beat 84 i think it was 84
pallets of
84 cases of water okay john
uh roll up your sleeves they need some
help getting those cases